this week at CPAC conservative leaders
are fighting back against the Democratic
Party's ongoing love affair with
socialism watch this under the guise of
Medicare for all and a green new deal
Democrats are embracing the same tired
economic theories that have impoverished
nations and stifled the liberties of
millions you know Margaret Thatcher
probably said it best
the trouble with socialism is that you
eventually run out of other people's
money they want to take your pickup
truck they want to rebuild your home
they want to take away your hamburgers
this is what Stalin dreamt about but
never achieved join us to put socialism
on trial and then convict it joining us
now with reaction Fox News contributor
Charlie heard former Obama economic
advisor
Austan Goolsbee and the person you just
saw in that video host of America first
on Salem radio Sebastian Gorka thank you
all three of you for joining us on this
this beautiful Friday night
Austin Democrats are not hiding they're
not hiding at all they put in socialism
right there front and center and they
are going for it it's only March 1st and
they are laying out everything from a
green deal it's a medicare-for-all - I
mean but it's going to cost and your
financial guy hundreds of trillions of
dollars how in the world do they think
this is going to sell to the American
people well you have chosen the most
extreme cases to try to make your point
and I think you got two dangers in that
first if you go to that CPAC meeting
where you took those speeches and you
find the most extreme people at that
meaning they are wackadoodle nuts and if
you were going to try to cast the entire
republican party as what somebody that
was on the most extreme thought it would
not be accurate but the second is as we
go into 2020 as you talk up that this is
going to be a socialist takeover it's
going to be like calling the poodle
killer
people are gonna see things like a
Medicare choice for all which is
supported by 73% of America and more
than 50% of Republicans Austin and
they're gonna say maybe this isn't so
bad maybe it's not socialism at all no
no Austin there are more than a hundred
people that have co-sponsored a bill
that says there will not be any private
insurance out there and Sebastian you
were there you were one of the speakers
there wackadoodle nuts i think is what
austin was referring to you as what was
the feeling that when but when the left
have no arguments they go at hominem
austin is just being another perfectly
good example of when the left runs out
of any ideas where the wackadoodles
seriously when alexandra or castillo
cortez talks about flatulent cows and
you've got to stop eating your
cheeseburgers where the extremists they
want to ban every single private vehicle
that runs on gas and disallow you from
using airplanes and where the extremists
this is the left in a nutshell the
radicals have taken over the democrat
party this is a party that isn't just
saying don't eat meat anymore this is a
party that says it is okay to kill
babies after they are born the butcher
of richmond Ralph Northam the governor
of New York
the radicals have taken over the asylum
and I guess Austin is one of them now I
want to be careful calling each other
names here but Charlie we're talking
about and call sebastian any names if it
was one of the speakers that is there
well he was one of the prime speakers
that look
Charlie these are bills that have been
introduced into Congress they've been
embraced by the major twenty twenty
candidates on the Left have they not
yeah and there's no doubt about it I
mean they were the standard that was set
by Bernie Sanders two years ago and in
the campaign that Hillary Clinton
wounded up wound up stealing from him
you know he set the standard every other
can
running this year this time around just
about has picked up the mantle of that
democratic socialism and the thing that
people have to remember is socialism is
not a platform of ideas and services and
and free stuff that they're going to
give away socialism is a form of tyranny
it's a form of running the government so
that you control people's lives at the
very all the way down to what they put
in their mouths and that is a very real
thing that's not something that's made
up and you can go back over the past
hundred years and you can see a hundred
million people have perished have been
killed under that kind of tyranny and
and the funny thing is when people when
Republicans try to address this stuff
seriously and they talk about the cost
of something like the new Green Deal or
do a green dream or whatever it is that
there's no money you you we
underestimate the power of socialism
socialism doesn't need money they have
prisons they can make people work and
that's what socialism is and you can you
can try to dress it up any you and any
way you want but that is undeniably what
socialism is and we have to combat it at
its root and Austin again you're a
numbers guy we're talking about two of
the biggest deals between the the new
Green Deal and Medicare for all
is that not hundreds of trillions of
dollars no it's not a that's not
hundreds of trillions be I'm not a
socialist I'm an economics professor
socialism doesn't work what they're
talking about with Medicare for all
there are many different bills you're
choosing only the most extreme one that
was put forward by Bernie Sanders the
Congressional Budget Office 2020 all
these 2020 candidates who embraced it
what was the twenty twenty candidates
Bernie Sanders is in favor of his own
bill which would cost a lot not a
hundred trillion but a lot and I'm not
the that Bernie Sanders fans are not a
big fan of mine because I have said that
it would be very expensive but the
Medicare for all that involves everyone
being able to choose to buy into
Medicare the Congressional Budget Office
says that saves money compared to the
current system it doesn't cost anything
it's literally less expensive than what
we have now
so no 170 in Boston you move 170 you're
gonna move 170 million people offer
their private insurance which is way
different to the Sebastian how do you
see this movement for it I mean they
Democrats have to the corner they have
painted themselves the former director
of the CBO the independent buy on you
know completely neutral CBO crunched the
numbers last week I discussed it on my
show every single American will have to
fund the green you deal to the cost of
$300,000 per person who's alive in
America those the figures and every
single person who is an official
candidate for the president's in the
Democrats has signed on to a Cassio's
deal this is the insanity you know your
your guest chart is absolutely right
socialism about is controlling every
aspect of your life if they control your
health care they've got everything if
they want to control what you are eating
that is totalitarianism and she said it
look Ocasio said it we've got to stop
eating cheeseburgers it's insanity
Jaison insanity charlie how do you see
younger people I mean younger people are
more idealistic don't have as much life
experience but is this a winning message
with you know somebody who's in their
20s and hey it sounds great everything
for free I I mean I hate to say it but I
think that there is some lure to it
people everybody likes free stuff
everybody likes the cheapest thing that
they can get the problem is that we've
done a poor job of reminding them ever
since the Soviet Union fell we do a poor
job of reminding people just how
terrible a way of life that is and and
we have a perfect example in Venezuela
right now everybody should see it and
watch it but we have to do a better job
of illustrating just how terrifying and
dangerous this is and Austin I'm so glad
you're against socialism but I wish that
your party would have a seat pack and
you could take all the people that are
running for president and go and talk to
them and explain to them how terrible
socialism is because it's really really
frightening and it's and it's very it's
very disheartening to see in
day and age a party where an alarming
number of its leaders or at least the
people that are seeking to lead the
party have fully embraced the concept of
it and I want to give Austin and
Sebastian I've got just 10 seconds for
each where is this going
the Democrats candidates for president
are going further and further to the
left are they not they're not going to
socialism and I just cautioned you guys
to be careful because you're trumping it
up like it's gonna be the biggest
socialist takeover ever and when people
see what it actually is they're gonna
say that doesn't seem so bad and then
you guys are gonna seem like a swim to
lunch well somebody is actually reading
the text of the bill and I got to tell
ya that is the direction that it is
going Sebastian well we'll all be out to
lunch if they banned cheeseburgers steak
and everything you want to eat Bernie
Sanders I played the audio on my show
today Bernie Sanders was asked does the
green dude New Deal go far enough and
Bernie said it doesn't go far enough the
lunatics have taken over the asylum
Jason gentlemen I appreciate y'all being
here tonight I hope you enjoy the rest
of your evening